dass wir heute hier stehen als große
starke volkspartei das zeigt wir halten
solche diskussionen aus wir lassen uns
nicht in den ruin hineinschreiben
und das ist wichtig das ist das signal
das sollte auch von diesem parteitag
ausgewählt die seit schlacht bei der cdu
ist ausgeblieben hier in leipzig beim
parteitag hat die vorsitzende annegret
kramp karrenbauer eine sehr engagierte
anderthalb stunden währende rede
gehalten in der sie sich fast
ausschließlich auf inhaltliche fragen
konzentrierte in der sie ein bild
skizzierte wie sie sich dass deutschland
das europa der zukunft vorstellte fast
schon eine rede wie eine
regierungschefin sie halten müsste
angela merkel hat nur ein grußwort
gesprochen aber annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat doch dann zweimal kurz
aber sehr deutlich in ihrer rede auch
den streit innerhalb der partei
aufgegriffen den streit mit friedrich
merz den streit mit jenem mann der knapp
gegen sie verloren hatte vor einem jahr
in hamburg und der gerade in jüngster
zeit die regierung der camkan bau
schließlich auch angehört sehr scharf
angegriffen hat anfangs hat sie gesagt
es könnte doch niemand glauben dass man
den wählern sagt die letzten 14 jahre
unter merkel dass er alles falsch
gelaufen und dann auch noch erwarte dass
man sie trotzdem wählen
das war aber nur das warmup liebe leute
das war alles falsch und alles schlecht
was in den letzten 14 jahren passiert
ist
ich meine ihr seid doch alle wahlkämpfe
rinnen und wahlkämpfer ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen wie man so wahlkampf
machen will wenn man auf der einen seite
den bürgern sagt es war alles schlecht
was wir gemacht haben
aber wir wären schon froh wenn er euch
nochmal welt damit wir es auch noch 14
jahre weitermachen können das ist keine
erfolgreiche wahlkampfstrategie und das
sollten wir uns das gar nicht
am ende ihrer rede ging sie sehr viel
weiter und legte ihre macht ihr amt als
parteivorsitzende für ein paar minuten
in die hände der delegierten sie sagte
nun sie habe das bild gezeigt wie sie
sich deutschland und europa vorstellen
wenn das aber etwas sei was den
vorstellungen der delegierten nicht
entsprechen was sie nicht wollten dann
sollte man das jetzt ansprechen und dann
sollte man jetzt aufhören das jetzt
beenden das heißt dann solle man auch
ihre amt als vorsitzenden beenden
aber ich will an dieser stelle auch
eines ganz offen sagen wenn ihr der
meinung seid dass dieses deutschland so
wie ich es möchte nicht dass deutschland
ist dass ihr euch vorstellt wenn ihr der
meinung seid dass dieser weg den ich
gemeinsam mit euch gehen möchte nicht
der weg ist denn ihr für den richtigen
halt dann lasst es uns heute aussprechen
und lasst es uns heute auch beenden hier
und jetzt und heute
dieses angebot wurde umgehend von den
delegierten abgelehnt sie spendeten ihm
stehend minutenlangen beifall
damit war klar zumindest für diesen
moment hat angriff kam kam bauer den
machtkampf in der cdu gewonnen
ob das allerdings reicht für die
nächsten monate für ein halbes jahr ein
ganzes jahr
ob das reicht für eine zeit wo die
umfragewerte noch weiter runtergehen für
die cdu dass das ist auf